Sam I gotta ask you the million dollar
question I don't know if you've seen far
from home not yet not yet okay am I
gonna give away a spoiler do you already
know what I'm gonna talk about coming
mid credits a certain person I did read
that tomorrow morning spider-man page
one with a decent picture this time did
you know this was happening in advance
were you given a heads up yes I was um
JK called me
I guess I'm spoiling it now so jakey
called me and said hey they're tracking
me about reprising my role what do you
think I said with with all my greatest
blessings because I love spider-man and
I love JK and he's I'd love to see more
of him so you take the pictures I'll
make up the headlines okay all right
that okay with you
yes sir goodie I mean everybody's scream
their head off probably as much as
they're going to incur oh oh yeah oh
there was an audio reaction oh my god it
was it pops on the screen everyone's
like oh my god really oh yeah Oh awesome
I cursed in front of a small child I
didn't mean to that's so cool
we love to terrify people and and
hopefully mostly with movies as opposed
to other type of terrifying people so
anyway that's what what Boyd got us like
excited that shared experience that fear
of like dark water what's underneath
what can grab you there was bad movies
about alligators and no one had really
done the jaws of alligators have you had
the chance to watch it with an audience
yet yes you did you did No well test
crowds yes that's true you're right Sam
I don't know only in its incomplete
statement I don't think we've ever seen
the finished film with the score and all
the finished effects in front of a crowd
right so what are what are their
reactions that you look for in the
audience during those test screenings
we've done it people yelling at the
screen we like that don't go in there
don't do that those sort of things and
nervous laughter we always love a good
nervous laughter just to like release
the tension crusing at the characters we
love that - yeah it's contained but is
there a possibility of a sequel or some
kind of crawl franchise that we could
get don't think he hasn't thought about
it just because Sam always said that so
I don't know I know Sam and Alex gotta
sit down and write it or something
probably the rez mucins Brothers and
Alex who wrote this one but I think if
the audience takes to it like we think
they will like they have so far they
probably will be more I think there's a
huge craving for this right now yeah
like this is what we want it's something
refreshing from you know big sequels and
stuff like that is yeah something people
haven't seen before it's hot popcorn fun
ride and with great tension